a border town in arizona is under a
state of emergency due to the migrant
surge tommy laron met with the mayor
of gila ben who is blaming the biden
administration for sending migrants to
his town
by bus i've never had drops here
before never during the trump
administration never even during the
obama biden administration i never had
drops here
now i'm seeing border patrol bring
people here and just drop them off
it's 30 miles to the next town over open
desert
you're going to walk people across that
desert in 120 degrees
you're going to find a lot of bodies but
again they're saying that this is not
unprecedented this has happened before
you're telling me this happened this is
a crisis
i i i don't want to play politics but
this is a crisis
pure and simple tommy joins us now with
more good morning to you tommy
good morning yeah you know it's amazing
when you actually go to these towns and
you actually speak to these mayors and
you speak to these landowners they're
telling you
that this is a crisis and they feel
largely ignored but you know kamala
harris she hasn't gone down she hasn't
done what i've done
but i can tell you after spending a
couple days with these folks it is a
crisis it is unprecedented and something
needs to be done
so what kinds of stories what'd you hear
from these ranchers down there
you know i spoke to one rancher and and
people that live in border towns
especially ranchers and border towns
they're used to having illegal
immigrants and migrants come across
their property but what they're seeing
right now
is unprecedented because those that are
coming across they're coming across
brazenly they're coming across feeling
as though they've been invited
you know some of the things that they're
finding and in some of the people that
they're
coming in contact with these are people
that are unapologetic about why they're
coming over
they feel it's their right to come over
they feel that they've been invited
and it's not going to stop anytime soon
you couple the halt and border wall
construction
with the messaging coming from the biden
administration the gaps the five mile
gaps that this one
rancher in particular is having to deal
with and you add in all those other
policies like taking away remain in
mexico and you've got the perfect storm
for a whole lot of problems down at the
border we have a clip of one of the
ranchers you talked to in nogales listen
to this
we find this quite often uh and the
carpet booties are used to
conceal the footprints uh make it harder
for the agents to track
because then they'll kind of scuff out
there so this is their own track this is
an example of a carpet bootie and it
fits over their shoes
everybody that's coming across is is
dressed in camouflage
these are sold as well on the other side
of the border and these are
like manufactured for people tommy are
they seeing more people on their
property than they used to
they are and you know beyond that i want
people to understand that this is this
rancher and other ranchers there this is
his livelihood
he's had his property set on fire he has
his fences cut
on a daily basis having to go and repair
them when you've got a ranch that's
thousands and thousands of acres
and you're having to spend your time
going and repairing fence and wiring
because the illegals are cutting it on a
daily basis they're sabotaging
your water supply they're lighting fires
i mean this is something that they are
dealing with
on a daily basis and normally they would
be able to call border patrol
and they would have more of an
opportunity to discuss these things with
border patrol and have a response
but border patrol has been sent now to
these processing and detention centers
to deal with the unaccompanied minors
coming through so they're not able to
respond like they used to
they're really being overworked their
resources are limited and now ranchers
like this are really concerned because
they've got a halton border wall which
was doing a lot of the work before
and they felt like maybe that would kind
of solve some of these problems but now
they're left completely exposed
they shouldn't have to be dealing with
this the biden administration needs to
answer for this
these are people's livelihoods and i
want people to also understand the
ranchers over on the mexican side
they also want border wall they also
want good policies because right now
they're having smugglers and cartel
using their property as a go-between
and they don't want that either these
are people that are living and working
their livelihood
is at stake so this is indeed a crisis
for so many
okay thank you so much tommy no
interruption it's on fox nation you'll
have to check it out we have more fox
and friends coming up
florida's governor ron desantis